Shalom, how we doing? I'm pretty good,
how are you? Blessed, highly favored.
I was I was just saying how you
how my Israelite brothers was like
what you call it? They failed they
failed against you, you know what I'm
saying? So, especially with the topic
about only
what you call it? Only Israelites
Israelites or the Gentiles are
Israelites like that's where Captain you
know Tazar Yac failed at, you know?
Everything else he was hitting on the
nail, but I just believe that the Holy
Trinity was you know added at the
Council of Constantinople, you know? So,
at the end of the day like the Bible
doesn't speak about the Holy Trinity.
So, with that being said I feel like
everybody like got good points, but I
seek the truth, you know? So, at the end
of the day I mean like saying Israelite
brothers saying that no other nation can
be saved is false. It goes against
Bible, it goes against you know
everything it talks about, you know?
Like I said, anybody that believes in
the laws of God and what you call it
believe in Jesus Christ can be saved,
you know?
>> Okay, so so you reject the deity of
Christ? No, I don't. I believe in Jesus
Christ, you know? Yahawashi Machiach I
believe in him, you know? I believe he's
the son of the Most High.
I believe he's the son of the Most High.
I believe there's only one God, you
know? Yahweh the Most High God and then
you know he has a son, you know? But as
far as like the Holy Trinity we know
that comes from you know it was added in
later, you know? By the Roman Empire,
you know? So,
It comes from the Bible, so that's
that's why I'm asking. So, you you
reject you reject the deity of Christ,
right? It sounds like. You talking about
as I reject the I reject the Holy
Trinity like that's not that's not of
the Bible. I mean Matthew 28:19 you know
it's considered altered text, you know?
But if you go back to the other It's not
you believe Matthew 28:19 is altered?
Yeah.
Do you have a a manuscript that says
otherwise? That says otherwise? Yeah, do
you have a manuscript of Matthew 28:19
that doesn't say in the name of the
Father, Son, and Holy Spirit, but says
something else? Yes, I do. Okay.
It's all right. You said it's a wrap? I
said it's all right. You can take your
time. No, I [clears throat] don't I
don't start talking trash until my
opponent starts talking trash. That's
when that's when I wake up. No, I'm with
you. Like I said, you have to go you
have to go back to the Hebrew. So,
Hebrew?
>> say? Go before what you call it, before
263 39 AD, you know, before you know,
before it was later added, it always say
go go and make disciples of all nations
in my name. Yeah, where does it say
that? Where Where do you I need a
manuscript of Matthew 28:19 that says
how you said it? Okay, well, we can go
back to other scriptures. We can go to
you know, Acts 2:38.
>> no, no, no. Acts 8:16.
>> no, no, no, no, no. Acts 10:48. Acts
19:5. No, no, no, no, no.
No.
No. I I I
No. No. Do you or do you not have a
manuscript of Matthew chapter 28:19 that
says otherwise
than
in the name of the Father, the Son, and
the Holy Spirit? Okay, we can go back to
the early uh historian Eusebius, you
know. We can go back We can go back to
that. I'm going to ask you again. Do you
or do you not have a manuscript of
Matthew 28:19
that says other than
in the name of the Father, the Son, and
the Holy Spirit? Okay, we We know that
we know We know Listen, we know as we
reconstruct the Greek text, we know
that. Um
but indubitably, like what you call it,
as far as like the Holy
Okay, I got a question for you, though.
No, no, no, no.
>> a question.
I got a question. I got a question. I
can ask you a question?
>> No. No, but what you call it, Bro, are
you good? I'm Oh, I'm good. I'm a little
bit under the weather, but I'm I'm good.
That's why I you know, question I asked
you, right?
>> Yes. So, do you have an answer to the
question I asked you cuz we're not going
anywhere until you're honest. Then we
can move forward, but you dodging my
question right now got me worried, man.
No, I'm not worried. I'm trying You're
saying, "Do I have the manuscript?" You
said, "Do I have the manuscript?" Mhm.
Yes.
>> Well,
I got I mean, I I have the Holy Bible
right here. What you call it?
I said Uh-huh. What you call I mean,
like I said, I read this front to backs
over six over six times, you know? Yeah.
And I even In that Bible, what's it say?
In Matthew 28:19, go ahead and read it
for me. 28:19,
you can bring it out. Yeah, let's bring
it out,
give me give me give me give me that
Matthew 28:19, man. We here. All right,
28:19, it says what it says, "Go you
therefore and teach all nations,
baptizing them in the name of the Father
and of the Son and the Holy Spirit."
Ruach Hakodesh.
Okay? Do you have
any manuscript of Matthew 28:19
that says otherwise? Yes or no? I do.
Sorry, I'm working on homework at the
same time, literally.
Uh
So, is it a yes or no? Do you have a
manuscript that says something else? On
my person right now, I do not.
You Have you ever seen Have you ever
seen a manuscript of Matthew 28:19 that
says something else? Have you ever seen
a textual variant there? You talking
Yeah, I mean, it's it's what you call
it. You can go to Eusebius, you know
what I'm saying?
>> No, Eusebius is not a textual variant.
He's a historian who is
>> Mhm.
interpreting texts, quoting it cuz he
also quotes it as Father, Son, and Holy
Spirit as well. He quotes it both ways.
Right? You said No, wait wait, repeat
that. You said he says it both ways.
Eusebius quotes it both ways. He quotes
it "Go out in my name." He also quotes
it "Go out in the name of the Father,
the Son, and the Holy Spirit." So, the
"in my name" part is a paraphrase that
Eusebius uses to encapsulate the whole
point. There's other places where he
quotes it verbatim, as we see in the
text. You talking Okay, we can go back I
mean like I said them them I guess it's
in the Greek, you know, the Leo
evangelica, you know, book three chapter
six, you know, you can go back to that,
you know, that's
as far as history goes, you know. As far
as what history?
But as far as the
what you call it uh
the when when it when the Holy Trinity
was changed, you know what I'm saying?
The Roman Empire. Is that Is that Is
that fact or is not fact? That's false.
So now now I see it in 325 AD, that's
false? Would you agree that Matthew was
written before Nicaea? Yeah yes, but
what you call it maybe earlier. On a
slip, do you agree that the way that you
just read Matthew 28:19 in the name of
the Father, Son, and Holy Spirit that
that's the Trinity? No, I don't agree
with that. No. So then why are you
fighting the verse so hard? No, I'm not
I'm not fighting I'm not fighting the
verse so hard. Like I said, I believe in
I believe in the text. Of course but of
course like with the Greek and
everything translations can be altered.
The mean The meaning
of things can be altered but at the end
of the day I believe
every other verse It's so many other
verses besides that one verse Okay.
That one verse is where you guys go with
the Holy Trinity. Okay, but
>> I didn't ask about where I go. I'm
asking
I'm asking you right now to be
intellectually honest with me. I am. It
says go and baptize in the name one name
of the Father, Son, and Holy Spirit. Is
that expressing the Trinity? Yes or no?
Right, but it was also what you Is it
yes or no? Is it that's how you that's
how you Christians interpret it.
>> ask if that's how we interpret Brother
No. You're making
>> I'm saying if
What you say? You're making me lose my
patience because you're not able to
answer a question straight away.
Is it or is it not expressing the
Trinity? I'm not asking how we interpret
it. I'm not asking how you interpret it.
I'm asking the text. Does the text
express the Trinity when it says go out
and baptize in one name, the singular
name, of the Father, the Son, and the
Holy Spirit. Is that a Trinitarian
expression? Yes or no?
I can I can say I'll say yes to your
your your uh what you call it. I I say
uh yes to what you're saying. Like
that's what Yeah, I'll say yes.
>> Thank you. So, according
>> According to the writing of Matthew, it
was written in the first century,
hundreds of years before the Council of
Nicaea and Constantinople and all this
kind of stuff. So, we have way before
these councils a Trinitarian verse and a
Trinitarian concept in the scripture.
Not at a council. But that Okay, okay.
Also, dude, for what you
What does it say? She So, at the end of
the day,
that is like the only verse in the whole
Bible though that expresses that. And
that's not the original wording of
Yahusha. No No worries. I see, and there
you are again. So, you acknowledge that
this is a verse that that proves the
Trinity, but you're saying that it's a
fabricated verse. So, I'm going to do
this again. I'm listening. I'm
listening. Do you have any
manuscript, text, verse regarding
Matthew 28:19
that says anything different from what
we have today? There's no There's no
surviving text of that, right?
You can agree with that? Can you agree
with that? Does that connect? Connect
I'm just saying. If it's
What I was What I was saying, if there's
no like Could that be true that there's
no surviving text of that? Could that be
true? Could that be true? That there was
once a text that existed like that, but
then now it doesn't? There's no
surviving text of that. Could that be
true? You know what? It could be true
that there's a pink uh pig with feathers
under my bed, you know? It could be
true, right? Could it be true?
It could be true, right? Could it be
true that there is
uh
a 66 wide pig
under my bed reading the gospel? That's
possible. Anything's possible, right?
All is possible with the Lord, right?
So, I agree. I agree.
>> with the Lord. I agree. I agree.
However, Go ahead. Go ahead.
>> there's absolutely no evidence. Can you
show me that Eusebius I'm sorry. Can you
show me that you see this evidence? Can
you show me that? Of course, I can show
you that. And then, once I show you
this, then you will accept that this
verse you will accept that this verse is
authentic, right?
>> I accept Jeremiah 8 and 8, you know.
>> that, I asked if I show you that
Eusebius quotes it exactly how we have
it in the scripture,
then that would prove for you that it
the scripture, right? Are you going to
put You're saying once you pull out
Eusebius
Is that what you're saying? If once you
pull out Eusebius, you're saying I'm
it's going to make me prove that it's
authentic. Is that what you're saying? I
don't understand. Is that what you said?
That's my question. Okay. I mean, I like
you said, it's possible. You know, it's
possible, you know.
>> That's not what I
I'm seeking like I said, I'm here to uh
what you call it? I seek I seek the
truth. If you're here seeking I'm going
to ask my question. If I show you Just
answer the question. Go ahead.
If I show you Eusebius quoting it how it
is in the Bible,
will that be proof that the text is
authentic? If you show me Eusebius
saying Okay, yeah. If you can show me
that Eusebius saying it otherwise that
in my name go and preach in in my name
Okay. I I'll take heed. I definitely
would take heed to that. If that was If
that was you saying. Like if if you can
show me that Eusebius said otherwise,
I'll take heed.
You know? I can agree I can agree with
that. But as as far as what I know, you
know what I'm saying? What the Most High
revealed to me, it's just like I see
like uh what you call it? I see like the
the truth not being
uh what you call it? Fully shown by both
sides, you know? I mean, with the with
you with you believe in, you know, Holy
Trinity, we know that's you know, that's
it's part of you know, Roman Roman uh
Roman matter of fact
the Bible as you just
>> One verse every every other verse says
go in my go with the might in the name
of Jesus Christ in the name of the Lord
Jesus.
>> What what other verse? What other verse?
Yeah, Acts 2 I mean go to the book of
Acts, you know. Acts 2:38.
>> about Matthew 28:19.
>> Right. I know that was the only verse
though that only one verse in the
>> there's if there's one verse where Jesus
gives the commission in the name of
Father, Son, and Holy Spirit, that's all
you need, right? But not one time do the
apostles not one time do the apostles
baptize in
>> Is that all you need? Is if Jesus says
it once, that's good enough, right?
>> Okay, I agree with I agree with Jesus at
the end of the day. But when the when
the apostles came the apostles of Jesus
Christ himself, right? None of them none
of them came baptizing in the name of
the Trinity. None of them. No, that's
that's your misunderstanding. If we see
Jesus says go out and baptize in the
name of the Father, Holy Spirit, and we
see the that Peter and them baptize in
the name of Jesus, they understand the
name of the Father, Son, and Holy Spirit
and the name of Jesus is identical. It
means that they're doing this in the
same authority, the same power,
the same source. That's what that means.
That's how they understood it.
Who is Or else, I guess what you have is
if we're going to go with you, then we
just have the the apostles disobeying
Jesus. No, I'm no, it's it's fact that
the apostles never never baptized in the
name of You can't pull it up nowhere in
the in the scripture.
>> hear what I said?
You're saying if they go with me
>> Break down Break down what I said, how I
explained it. Break it down. If you
can't, then I'mma move on. I No, I get
what you I get what you I Listen.
>> Break it down. What I said. You're
saying you you basically saying if Jesus
said it one time, it's it's okay, you
know. You That's what you're saying.
What did I What did I say in response to
your argument about the apostles not not
using it the way Jesus had it in Matthew
28? What did I say to that? Can you Can
you repeat Can you repeat it?
Okay.
Take care, bro. Take care. Uh that's
maybe maybe there's another man out
there, another
person who can have enough patience and
plant the seed with you,
but you're too dishonest, you're not
listening, you're stuck in your way
to where I can't help you. I can't help
you. Maybe there might be somebody else
who can reach you, but I can't. You're
too dishonest for me. Too dishonest
waste of time for me.
So, take care of yourself, man. Go go
somewhere else. Reflect on what we
talked about today. But just for you
though, just for you I will show the
Eusebius quote. So, keep watching. I'll
show the Eusebius quote. We're We're
done talking. And don't come back here
again to talk to me unless you humble
yourself and you're willing to listen
and be honest and directly answer
questions and be intellectually have
intellectual integrity. Until then, we
cannot talk. But let me show you the
Eusebius quote. And saying, man.
I'm going to go around and around and
around with folks who are just
dishonest. Not going to do it. If I was
life, I would have been yelling right
now.
It's gone. It's gone. Logic's It's gone.
Why specifically 2100? Cuz that's the
price I put up there. Eusebius quotes,
Matthew 28:19.
So, this is
If I am reading this correctly, the
Roman numeral If the one goes before the
five, then that's four. Book four. Book
four. Yep, it says it right here. The
fourth book of Eusebius of
uh
Caesarea. Caesarea. Caesarea. Okay? Now,
let's control F it and let's put Oh,
look at that.
So, down when we get to what what do
they call these? Number eight. Um not
paragraph, but I guess section eight, I
don't know. All right, so this is
Eusebius fourth book of
uh Caesarea. Eusebius fourth book of
Eusebius of Caesarea. Watch what it says
here. Watch what it say, baby. Make sure
we can all look at it.
>> [clears throat]
>> After the resurrection from the dead,
all of them all of them being together
as they had been commanded, went to
Galilee as he had said to them, but when
they saw him, some worshipped him, but
others doubted. But he drew near to
them, spoke with them, and said, "All
power in heaven and on earth is given to
me by of my father. Go ye
and make disciples of all nations, and
baptize them in the name of the Father,
the Son, and of the Holy Ghost, and
teach them to observe all that I
commanded you." You see? This is
Eusebius
quoting it exactly how it is in Matthew
28:19. Sorry if it's too small. There we
go.
Here it is. There it is. Marsha, sure.
So, with that being said, if you're
still going to be dishonest, you can be
dishonest somewhere else, my guy.